wichtiger schritt im kampf gegen korona
piontek und pfizer beantragen eine
notfall zulassung für ihren impfstoff in
deutschland werden erste impfzentren
aufgebaut
gefährliche route über den atlantik auf
ihrem weg nach europa landen viele
flüchtlinge auf den kanarischen inseln
geburtsstunde des völkerstrafrechts
heute vor 75 jahren begannen die
nürnberger prozesse ns-verbrecher
mussten sich vor gericht verantworten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute um 19 uhr an einem ereignisreichen
nachrichten tag auch im sport stehen hat
norbert könig für uns denn bei andere
mit tennis genommen selten wurde ein
pharmaprodukt weltweit so sehnsüchtig
erwartet ein impfstoff gegen das corona
virus kommt aus mainz und den usa und
ist nach ersten testungen zu 95 prozent
wirksam
heute wird seine notfall zulassung in
den usa und europa beantragt die zeit
drängt denn mittlerweile hat die zahl
der neuansteckungen in deutschland
wieder einen höchststand erreicht
in den letzten 24 stunden wurden 23 1648
neue infektionen bestätigt so viele wie
noch nie und 106 mehr als am vergangenen
freitag vor diesem hintergrund sind das
also gute nachrichten die von biontech
und weise kommen
sie hoffen auf eine zulassung noch bis
ende des jahres marion geiger der
impfstoff von biontech und weise eine
riesen hoffnung für die welt denn er
soll zu 95 prozent wirksam sein
in den usa wird er nun auf den weg
gebracht die beantragung einer notfall
zulassung in den usa ist ein
entscheidender schritt um unseren
impfstoffkandidaten so schnell wie
möglich der weltbevölkerung zur
verfügung zu stellen
der impfstoff ist an 43.000 menschen
getestet wurden nach angaben von bayern
tag und weiser wurden dabei keine
schwerwiegenden nebenwirkungen
festgestellt deshalb rechnen sie mit
einer schnellen zulassung
sobald wir grünes licht haben ist es
unser ziel innerhalb weniger stunden mit
der auslieferung zu beginnen
für die eu wird der antrag auf zulassung
in kürze erwartet das verfahren läuft
dann so der hersteller beantragt die
zulassung bei der emea der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur ema prüft ob der
impfstoff hochwertig wirksam und sicher
ist falls ja empfiehlt sie die zulassung
die entscheidung liegt bei der
eu-kommission biontech und weise haben
vorab schon studiendaten eingereicht
damit am
schneller entschieden werden kann ohne
abstriche bei der sicherheit
beschleunigt klingt für viele
beteiligten ja so dass es die studien
verkürzt werden aber dem ist nicht so
das einzige was hier beschleunigt wird
das ist der administrative prozess der
zulassung da langfristige daten über
sicherheit und wirksamkeit noch fehlen
wird eine zulassung mit auflagen
erwartet wir möchten natürlich auch eine
langzeit verfolgung haben das heißt
unerwartete effekte die wir jetzt nicht
im blick haben die vielleicht auch bei
den tierversuchen ich aufgetreten sind
möchten wir messen möchten wir gemeldet
bekommen
wenn alles gut läuft könnte der
impfstoff in europa noch im dezember auf
den markt kommen
das eine ist hoffentlich schon bald über
einen impfstoff zu verfügen das andere
aber die praktische anwendung wer wird
wann wo und wie geimpft so viele
erfahrungen gibt es ja nicht mit
massenimpfungen in der neueren zeit
logistisch eine ziemliche
herausforderung wie man die zu meistern
gedenkt hat sich julia schröter erklären
lassen
noch ist die messehalle in trier
doch schon in wenigen tagen soll hier
ein im zentrum stehen der ort scheint
optimal viel platz verkehrsgünstig
gelegen viele parkplätze schon im sommer
haben feuerwehr und stadt gemeinsam ein
konzept für das impfzentrum erarbeitet
es sieht so genannte impfstraßen vor wie
am fließband geht die zu impfenden
person von station zu station
zuerst geht es zur registrierung dann
gibt es ein kurzes gespräch mit einem
arzt im nächsten bereich wird die
impfung verabreicht
anschließend kann man sich in einem
ruhebereich etwas ausruhen kalkulierte
dauer etwa 15 minuten unter volllast von
16 bis maximal 20 im straßen könnten wir
rein rechnerisch auch 5000 impfungen am
tag durchführen
die idee erstmal in zentren zu impfen
kommt bei den hausärzten in den
bundesländern größtenteils gut an auch
weil der ansturm gerade zu anfang im
praxisalltag kaum zu stemmen wäre
bis jetzt ist es so dass in fast allen
ländern viele aus setzte sich bereits
freiwillig bereit erklärt haben
auch in diesen impfzentren
die teams mitzuhelfen und die einsätze
werden kommen auch in trier
mit etwas glück sind sie hier schon in
zehn tagen einsatzbereit jetzt muss nur
noch der impfstoff kommen die afg und
die störaktion im bundestag das war
heute auch thema im parlament in einer
aktuellen stunde
das gäste von afg abgeordneten
parlamentarier beleidigten und
bedrängten sei mehr als ein tabubruch so
redner und rednerinnen der anderen
parteien
es sei ein angriff auf die demokratie
bundestagspräsident schaible will alle
rechtlichen möglichkeiten gegen die
verantwortlichen prüfen
thomas reichert eigentlich will sich die
afg an diesem tag im parlament
entschuldigen aber dann wird es doch
wieder laut und empört der
fraktionsvorsitzende erklärt zunächst
mit den afd gästen sei etwas aus dem
ruder gelaufen
das gewählte volksvertreter von gästen
zweier abgeordneter unserer fraktion
bedrängt und belästigt wurden ist
unzivilisiert und gehört sich nicht
dafür entschuldige ich mich als
fraktionsvorsitzender
die beiden abgeordneten die die störe
ins parlament ließen würden das auch
schriftlich beim bundestagspräsidenten
tun während der debatte in das wirken
sie auf vieles ginge sie das nichts an
für die anderen fraktion ist die
entschuldigung deshalb nicht glaubhaft
die angriffe im parlament seien teil
einer demokratiefeindlichen strategie
der afd ihrer fraktion wird hier
provoziert dass man dieses parlament
verachten will und was sie nicht selbst
erledigen das lassen sie durch
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
erledigen die sie ganz offenbar unter
dem gesichtspunkt auswählen wer denn
wohl der skrupellosesten sei in seltener
einigkeit verurteilen alle von
linkspartei bis union das geschehen als
angriff auf die parlamentarische
demokratie
diese demokratie hat aus weimar gelernt
sie ist standhaft und sie ist wehrhaft
und sie erreichen nicht das was sie
wollten und bei aller
unterschiedlichkeit in der sache
zwischen fdp cdu csu und grünen spd und
linken werden wir dies zusammen tun
es ist eine generalabrechnung mit der
afd
derweil lässt der bundestag prüfen
welche rechtlichen konsequenzen den
beteiligten drohen
bis sonntag debattieren die grünen auf
ihrem digitalen bundesparteitag über ein
neues grundsatzprogramm wegen corona
werden die delegierten per video
zugeschaltet nur parteivorstand und
präsidium sind in berlin versammelt
kontroverse debatten werden bei den
themen klimaziele gentechnik und
soziales grundeinkommen erwartet mit dem
neuen programm wollen die grünen die
weichen stellen für die bundestagswahl
im nächsten jahr
der umgang mit fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs sorgt weiter für unruhe in
der katholischen kirche in scharfer form
kritisiert die vollversammlung des
zentralkomitees der katholiken den
kölner kardinal woelki weil er ein
gutachten zurück hält das offenbar die
vertuschung von missbrauch belegt wir
sind ernüchtert beschämt und zornig
heißt es in einer erklärung des zdk
es gebe noch immer bischöfe die ihre
macht missbrauchten und keine
verantwortung übernehmen
in den usa ist präsident tram sozusagen
abgetaucht öffentliche termine etwa um
über das problem zu beraten
fehlanzeige aber die behauptung dass nur
er und nicht joe biden der legitime
wahlsiege sei bringt er weiter und das
volk zuständig für wüste theorien von
wahlbetrug ist neben rechten medien
hauptsächlich trumps anwalt rudy
giuliani und nun wird klar falls auch
dessen letzte klage bemühungen scheitern
könnte dass trump lager sogar versuchen
das wahlergebnis einzelner staaten mit
tricks auszuhebeln eines traums
er lässt sich nicht blicken aus dem
weißen haus heraus agiert präsident
trump aber weiter gegen das wahlergebnis
seine klagen gegen die stimmauszählung
wurden von den gerichten abgeschmettert
nun schickt er seinen anwalt auf pr-tour
um zweifel am wahlausgang zu sehen ist
nicht zu fassen die software-firma die
unsere stimmen ausgezählt hat gehört
zwei venezolanern die mit hugo chavez
verbündet waren die an der seite von
maduro stehen während er
verschwörungstheorien verbreitet läuft
dem anwalt haarfärbemittel über die
schläfen trump will einen kniff der
verfassung nutzen und die auswahl der
wahlleute in den bundesstaaten
beeinflussen die kommen normalerweise
von der siegreichen partei sind sie
nicht bis zu einer frist benannt könnten
republikanisch dominierte
landesparlamente nur republikaner
ernennen und den wählerwillen ignorieren
der gewählte präsident fassungslos wir
senden unglaublich schädliche
botschaften an den rest der welt wie
unsere demokratie funktioniert ich kenne
sein motiv nicht aber es ist völlig
verantwortungslos die republikaner
stehen weiterhin zu trump nur einzelne
sprechen von einem angriff auf die
demokratie funktioniert unser staat wir
zählen die stimmen und leben mit dem
ergebnis wir hatten immer eine
friedliche übergabe der macht es traurig
was hier passiert schämt euch rufen
demonstranten als zwei republikaner aus
dem landesparlament von michigan in
washington ankommen trump erwartet sie
wohl um sie für seine neue taktik zu
gewinnen frage an unseren us
korrespondenten elmar t wissen wie groß
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese
trump taktik aufgehen könnte also den
klaren sieg von joe biden auszulöschen
oder umzudrehen das wäre ja so eine art
umsturz von oben das halte ich für sehr
unwahrscheinlich es müsste ja
gleichzeitig in mehreren bundesstaaten
gelingen
aber ich halte es auch nicht für ganz
ausgeschlossen die republikaner müssen
sich jetzt entscheiden ob sie dem
amerikanischen
volk dienen oder einem abgewählten
präsidenten der sie gewissermaßen ein
stück weit als erfüllungsgehilfen
missbrauchen will wenn sie sich weigern
dann wird am 14
dezember wenn das wahlmänner kollegium
zusammen tritt joe biden klar zum
präsidenten gewählt aber donald trump
hat vielleicht trotzdem ein ziel
erreicht nämlich bei seinen anhängern
dann nicht mehr als wahlverlierer
sondern als kämpfer dazustehen als opfer
einer zweifelhaften wahl und ich glaube
darum geht es ihm eigentlich er will
gewissermaßen joe biden entgegen allen
beweisen ein etikett an hängen nämlich
das etikett des mannes der eine
illegitime präsident werde
vielen dank für die erklärung elmar auf
den spanischen kanaren zeichnet sich
eine neue flüchtlingskrise ab nahezu
täglich erreichen boote die inseln
18.000 menschen sind schon in diesem
jahr dort angekommen im ganzen jahr 2009
10 waren es nur etwa 2700 weil andere
migrations routen streng überwacht
werden wagen sich die menschen auf den
viel gefährlicheren seeweg über den
atlantik hunderte kilometer von marokko
mauretanien und sogar vom senegal aus
einer hand berichtet gestrandet in
arguineguin in dem kleinen hafen auf
gran canaria campieren seit wochen
tausende migranten kein wasser kein
essen kein schlaf hilferufe auf
schildern es fehlt an betten an
toiletten die lokalen behörden sind
überfordert
entweder muss gestapo für wir glauben
dass der druck noch zunehmen und der
zustrom der menschen nicht nachlassen
wird deshalb müssen wir uns dringend
besser darauf vorbereiten damit wir all
diese frist linge aufnehmen können
seitdem die route über das mittelmeer
streng kontrolliert wird versuchen
wieder mehr afrikaner über den atlantik
nach europa zu kommen
eine der gefährlichsten routen überhaupt
sie fliehen vor armut gewalt politischer
verfolgung und wegen der pandemie kommen
kaum noch touristen in ihre länder es
fehlt an jobs und perspektiven
wir haben alles dafür gegeben um nach
europa zu kommen um hier geld zu
verdienen
ich habe dem tod ins auge geblickt vier
nächte habe ich auf see verbracht
die spanische regierung erlaubt keine
weite reise aufs festland einige hundert
flüchtlinge werden nun in einem
militärcamp untergebracht doch das
entlastet die insel kaum
die bewohner sind beunruhigt und sie
haben angst
es betrifft doch unser leben hier vor
ort
die insulaner fühlen sich von der
zentralregierung allein gelassen
denn tag für tag kommen mehr migranten
über das meer
hier wurde zeitgeschichte geschrieben
vor 75 jahren
denn hier standen verantwortliche des
nazi regimes vor gericht
im saal 600 des justizpalastes in
nürnberg november 1945 göring hess
ribbentrop insgesamt 21 nazigrößen
müssen sich vor dem tribunal der
siegermächte verantworten für terror
krieg und barbarei mit millionen toten
er soll recht gesprochen nicht rache
geübt werden
in diesem saal wird auch erstmals der
tatbestand verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit geprägt nach 218
prozesstagen und 240 angehörten zeugen
verkünden die alliierten richter 12
todesurteile drei freisprüche sowie
haftstrafen
weitere prozesse folgten barbara lueg
und jutta sonne waldbericht als die
richter damals eintreten steigt die
spannung im saal die dramatik ist
spürbar kaum eine regung wie erstarrt
folgen die angeklagten der
urteilsbegründung werden später
gerichtsreporter schreiben
kriegsverbrecher wie hermann göring und
rudolf es sitzen auf der anklagebank
er ist einer der wenigen noch lebenden
zeitzeugen benjamin fairen als junger
soldat erlebte die befreiung mehrerer
konzentrationslager seine aufgabe
beweise für die gräueltaten der nazis zu
sammeln
der junge redegewandte us-anwalt wird
chef ankläger in einem der zwölf
sogenannten nachfolgeprozesse ich war
wütend
ich dachte diese kerle lässt du nicht
davonkommen ich habe millionenfacher
mörder in der
hand und so kam es dass ich in meinem
ersten fall als anwalt chef der anklage
wurde im größten mordprozess der
menschheitsgeschichte zum tode
verurteilt wird damals auch hans frank
ein früherer weggefährte adolf hitlers
und später generalgouverneur im
besetzten polen verantwortlich für die
ermordung von millionen von menschen so
niklas frank trägt seit jahrzehnten als
stete mahnung das foto seines gehängten
vaters bei sich hat nie wirklich
wirklich bereut was er angerichtet hat
das verstehe ich nicht so da werde ich
dann wieder sauer und könne ihm auch
diese hinrichtung
so haben die nürnberger prozesse damals
den grundstein für die verfolgung von
völkermord gelegt und damit für die
suche nach gerechtigkeit für die opfer
von massenverbrechen harter schnitt und
wir sind beim sport da ist alexander
zverev in london ausgeschieden aber
norbert er kann ganz zufrieden sein mit
seinem tennis jahr dagegen absolut 2 4
endspiel erreicht und zwei turniersiege
geschafft das ist eine respektable
bilanz eines geschrumpften tennisjahres
mit dem einzug ins halbfinale der atp
finals hat es aber nicht geklappt novak
djokovic nummer eins der welt war
stärker es dauert lange bis alexander
zverev ins spiel findet novak djokovic
setzt den deutschen von beginn an unter
druck gewinnt bereits wäre als erstes
aufschlagspiel und nach 33 minuten den
satz mit 6 zu 3
danach wäre ebenbürtig variabler und für
den spitzenreiter der weltrangliste ein
echter problem gegner beide gewinnen
jeweils ihre aufschlagspiele erst im
tie-break setzt sich djokovic durch nach
einer stunde und 36 minuten gewinnt der
serbe mit 6 zu 3 7 zu 6 und steht im
halbfinale
für alexander zverev ist damit dieses
tennisjahr beendet
der sechzehnte geburtstag normalerweise
ein grund für eine große party aber
heute aus verschiedenen gründen kein
thema für yusuf amoco er muss morgen
topfit sein für den fall dass er als
jüngster bundesligaspieler der
geschichte sein debüt für borussia
dortmund gibt im abendspiel bei hertha
bsc
josef amoco schon am samstag dürfte er
treffen alt genug wäre der teenie
stürmerstar des bvb seit heute doch
trainer lucien favre gibt sich zunächst
zurückhaltend wir werden sehen heute ob
er mit der mannschaft kommt nach dem
tennis noch nicht entscheiden
mukoko war seinen jeweiligen
altersgenossen schon sehr früh
entwachsen ob bei der borussia oder bei
den jugend nationalmannschaften mit 16
nun bei den profis weil sein talent
herausragend ist und dass dieses
potenzial
er ist schon sehr sehr gut gut mit der
erste mannschaft er muss großen druck
aushalten schon jetzt was da im moment
medial abgeht das gefällt mir nicht dass
das das geht mir zu weit
nach dem abschlusstraining dann doch wo
coco steht im kader gegen hertha mit
einer menge einstürzen auf den sehr
jungen mann dann gedauert und wir haben
zum schluss noch eine geschichte eine
schöne geschichte eines kleinen vogels
der sich unfreiwillig und per lastwagen
auf eine weite reise begab
beim aufstellen des weltberühmten
weihnachtsbaums in new york vor dem
rockefeller center entdeckte ein
arbeiter die kleine eule ausgehungert
und durstig nun wird der kauz mit
reichlich mäusen wieder aufgepäppelt
morgen darf der kleine rockefeller
wieder zurück in die freie natur zum
wetter das wird sehr unterschiedlich im
norden trüb im süden dagegen sonnig mehr
dazu gleich von gunther tiersch das war
es von uns danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
christian sievers erwartet sie heute um
10 zum heute journal
und hier übernimmt morgen barbara halle
in einen entspannten freitagabend und
noch ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]
genau wie die zuschauer morgen gibt's
bei und seine deutliche zweiteilung auch
in norddeutschland wird es wieder trüb
sein und es kann auch hier und da ein
bisschen regen wolken von der nordsee
ziehen heran und sie gehören eben zu dem
sturmtief bei island der süddeutschland
haben wir den hohen luftdruck und da
lösen sich die meisten wolken auf also
deutliche unterschiede
heute nacht geht es dann schon mal los
da haben wir nebelfelder in
süddeutschland bei klarem himmel in der
zweiten nachthälfte schon wieder
leichten regen an den küsten und einen
starken südwestwind
zwar bleibt es dann etwas milder im
nordwesten sonst gibt es leichten frost
in der mitte und im süden 0 bis -7 grad
und tagsüber sind es dann
plus 2 bis plus sieben grad nur im
westen wird es milder
das liegt an dem starken süd west winter
sind es zehn elf grad und es stark
bewölkt rüth immer wieder fällt leichter
sprühregen der zieht von west nach ost
über norddeutschland hinweg über den
mittelgebirgen noch etwas auf aber es
südlich des mains wird es freundlicher
an den alpen und im schwarzwald scheint
die sonne
die aussichten für den sonntag sehen
ganz ähnlich aus auch in der neuen woche
bleibt es leicht wechselhaft mal ist es
trüb mal scheint die sonne
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut